Hằng miền tăng đi, phật tử, người dân tập trung về công việc lấy thị dân
nếu từng là những trang bô thành,
để tham dự lấy câu xeu từng nghiệp cách liệt sĩ và đồng bảo vụ nước.
Trong trình gió bàn trị sĩ gió vụ phật giáo kịch Nam thành hỗ hỗ trình tổ chức.
Ở này rất là trang nghiêm, nhưng mà mình nghĩ đến,
các cạnh phần nâng đã hình sân nó rất hợi sự gạo,
mình khiến tại vì đang xong hỏa cái nợi phà mình là cũng nhờ âm khổ át các tý dễ.
Hôm nay, cá là đàn,
hình xứng lúc, tổ tân tệ,
và trang có kí sĩ.
Lúc xe, em cầm lúc nữa là không hoa được này,
em có thể tình hãy có kí sĩ,
đều lắm là phá hợi đẹp vệ cho gia đình.
Mình lúc nhất nhớ các con,
tại vì đều rối chóng các vầy,
thì anh không để sĩ đã hình xin nhớ,
nó phá phá phát quay,
học tạm nhớ, phải qua đơn này.
Họt đậm giến ra trong bối cạnh thành phố Hổ Chí Minh,
đang trên thai tim tiếng cuy tập hai quốc lịch sĩ
thì xin trong chính sịch mục thân một chính sấu tảm.
Theo nhóm nghiên cứu,
tại cú bột trung viên có thể còn bà rất mục tập thề,
được cho là nơi ăn bán khoảng chính trong lịch sĩ và đồng bảo.
Phó thị biến phạm thị thang chả,
đã yêu cầu yên bán nhân dân thành phố Hổ Chí Minh,
và nhanh thịt phương ánh khảo xa tực biệt
hổ chất khai quốc tìm tiếng và vui tập trước nền mấy tảm thằng sau.